indeed a lot of people that just
finished their studies
imagine that we sit all day and we read
papers and we develop algorithms and we
talk about science
and in practice data science is a lot
about the business
meaning we're getting paid to create
models that make real impact
on the companies we work at welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford
leap and birthright excel welcome to 20
minute leaders in this episode we're
going to unfold the role of the data
scientist
meet aviv benedi staff data scientist at
intuit
previously a lead data scientist at
paypal she specializes in fraud
prevention and cyber security
and in the past worked at the prime
minister's office in the cyber security
field
focusing on protocol analysis i've
graduated from tel aviv university with
the double bsc in computer science and
life science
while specializing in bioinformatics
aviv ben airy welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from the intuit
offices at petertigva how are you
i'm doing great how are you thank you
very very much for joining me aviv
your journey as a data scientist across
multiple organizations
including data scientists within a
paypal now
staff data scientist that intuit i'm
looking forward to talking with you
about data science
as a as an industry as a vertical as a
new
as a new you know type of occupation
that didn't necessarily exist
you know before and and i'd love to
start with a little bit about your
journey and where you're coming from and
how you even got introduced
to data science and then we'll dig deep
into what data science is and all that
fun stuff
um great so actually i began my journey
more in the cyber security space not as
a data scientist before data science was
a very widespread occupation
i in the army i was in a very large
technological unit which is focused on
cyber security and i worked at the
israel prime minister office
and while working there i studied
computer science and i fell in love with
algorithms research and data science
and from there i learned that i can
actually combine my two passions
and work in the cyber security and fraud
domain
while being a data scientist so this is
how i uh
i got to my first data science position
at paypal around five and a half years
ago
and from there i began my journey in the
industry i'm still working in the fraud
domain which i absolutely love
and i'm really happy to do to combine
both data science and this fascinating
domain
so when you when we say the word data
scientist what does that actually mean
to you
so a data scientist in the industry is
maybe different from what
people imagine in academia for example
people that are
researching and creating new machine
learning algorithms
in the industry a data scientist would
spend most of his time
working on a specific business problem
and deriving a machine learning solution
that can somehow have a good business
impact
on that problem for example i work in
the fraud prevention domain
i receive specific tasks for my business
partners to prevent fraud at intuit or
paypal
and i'm in charge of understanding which
data i can utilize
and how to leverage my vast knowledge of
algorithms and machine learning
to create a model that ends up in
production meaning my models work in
real time every time you hit
login in paypal or send a transaction
and these models specifically prevent
fraud and this can be applied to any
domain
and so when you're talking about you
know models and
and predictive models and you know
obviously we have anomaly detection and
a lot of these you know ways in which
data science and machine learning
can be used within organizations
historically what are we seeing so what
how is the trend
come about to be to to data science
let's say in the last 10 or 15 years
so i'd like to share my personal
experience i
started looking for my first data
science job
around six seven years ago and there
were almost
zero such positions in israel and tel
aviv is a great
high tech hub yes there were technical
analyst
jobs and things that were like in
direction
but only around i would say five four to
five years ago it began
began to be a position that every
company wants to open
and hire great data scientists so i
would say that 10 years ago this wasn't
really common practice in the industry
and i feel that the trend is now that
every company even small
startups now have some data science team
or even a group
and it's something that really became a
commodity everyone wants to use ai
and actually as a data scientist i would
say that my job
gets a bit easier on the technical
aspects
um there's a lot of tools that when i
began working
didn't even exist a lot of the more
advanced machine learning packages for
example tensorflow or keras
didn't even exist when i started working
which is just
goes to show you how fast this field uh
advances
so things have gotten easier maybe on
the technical side and more advanced now
we use platforms for example aws and gcp
and cloud computing
in the past training very heavy models
was a very difficult task that only very
wealthy companies were able to pay for
and also i would say that people are
looking to study this field more and
more
in the past the field was much less
competitive than it is today
i interview new hires for intuit and we
have so many applications for every open
position
so i would definitely say this is still
i would say i think it's still
very trending i don't see any decline in
um the number of open positions or in
the number of candidates
that we have um also universities
started
having started um opening master degrees
in data science specifically where in
the past it was just like one sub domain
within the computer science um master's
degree
um now there's full trainings that are
focused on
training the best data scientists for
the future
um so
this trend so so i understand that
there's this great trend that we're
saying in terms of
you know the organizations and
understanding that we have a lot of
these new technologies that are enablers
for people to become better data
scientists what are we seeing a similar
trend also in terms of the
the people that are entering the
workforce that may have to upskill in
order to be data scientists or perhaps
are looking you know at what to study
now
so definitely um as one of my uh
my volunteering side jobs i would say i
mentor
female data scientists that are looking
for their next job through an israeli
community called extend
and i'm very aware of the changes in the
workforce
as part of this mentoring program
because i constantly
are i'm in touch with people looking for
their next job not
only while i'm searching for the next
position
and i can definitely say that things are
getting much
more difficult for the candidates if in
the past it was
enough to have a bachelor's degree in
computer science and some
maybe some additional training today
without a master's degree
and a thesis in the very specific field
of machine
a specific field of machine learning for
example nlp or computer vision
it's very difficult um to obtain the
first job
and in general people are looking also
for experience not only for theoretical
knowledge
so i i would say that the barriers are
getting much higher it's getting more
and more difficult to enter the field
but also i think that there's a lot more
trainings available there's courses for
example itc
and y data there's master's degree in
the uh technion in tel aviv university
so it's it's easier to obtain the
knowledge when i studied it was very
difficult to find the relevant courses
and
projects to really gain more knowledge
and today i feel that it's
becoming more easier to find the
training to take it
and then finding the actual job after
may be a bit
challenging and my best advice is to
gain real
work experience even if it's just a
volunteer work or an open source project
but
um have something you can show in the
interviews to prove that you really know
how to apply the knowledge to real world
world problems
and so how what is the you know paying
me a picture of them the day-to-day of a
data scientist because i think that's
also something that that is pretty
interesting
and could be a little bit different than
what people may imagine well what is the
traditional day of a data scientist look
great question so indeed a lot of people
um that just finished their studies
imagine that we sit all day and we read
papers and we develop algorithms and we
talk about science
and in practice data science is a lot
about the business
meaning we're getting paid to create
models that make real impact on the
companies we work at
so a lot of my day goes into meetings
with different stakeholders
with my development team with my
business analysts
some companies have acute maybe qa teams
and really aligning
connecting all the dots to make sure
that the models i'm
training are going to solve the business
problem in hand
if i create an amazing model in terms of
machine learning but at the end the
business kpis don't go up or down as
expected
i didn't really do my job meaning my
um the end the end goal of my model is
always to push some business kpi
um and not just uh make a an amazing
machine learning model
so part we have a lot of meetings
a lot of alignment of course we do have
a lot of i would say around half of my
time goes into reading papers
and actually writing code training the
models fine-tuning them
writing production code deploying to
production this is also something that
has changed throughout the years
now data scientists are expected to be
really well-rounded and be very fluent
in
coding deploying to production
really own the entire pipeline not just
know how to take care of the machine
learning part
so basically our work is end to end i
work with the business i gather the data
i clean the data i train the model i
write the production code deploy to
production write the monitoring
make sure that all the business kpis are
measured well
and get feedback that if my model is
working or not
sometimes we have to do another round of
training so
we really have to take care of the
entire pipeline not just
the fun machine learning part
right and it sounds like one of the most
important things to to keep in mind
especially for those that aren't
familiar with machine learning or data
science says you know in the ins and
outs of it at the end
it's the connection to the business
purpose right and it's the connection to
the kpis of the company
and you're not just somebody who's
sitting down and writing math equations
you're actually the one who's receiving
the raw data you have to clean it you
have to
to fine-tune it to your business needs
and
with if you don't understand the
business needs you might create
a nice model but it's not going to do
what the business needs it to do right
exactly for example um the one of the
reasons i really love working and
specifically in the fraud domain and
when i moved into it i was specifically
looking for a position in this domain
is that i have a very rich background in
cyber security and fraud
and i feel that the combination between
business knowledge and domain knowledge
and
my technical capabilities drives better
results than
a person that's an amazing data
scientist knows machine learning well
but has no idea
um what what what the different fraud
mo's are
how people why would people commit fraud
different techniques
so i really feel that a strong business
sense is
makes a great data scientist as opposed
to just the technical aspects of the job
so if you have to go back and to talk to
aviv
you know five and a half years ago that
is now joining let's say paypal or is
joining
you know her first data science role in
a in a corporate
what what what did you learn over these
last these last few years
that is not trivial but you're saying
this is something that is key to my
success as a data scientist
so as we already talked about i think i
had no idea how important um the
connection with the businesses
um i was very fascinated by the math
part and at the beginning i
didn't really understand the product
enough
so definitely get to know the product
better
into it is all about customer obsession
and i think this is a really critical
part for
for any job but specifically for data
scientists and really understand what
the company is all about what the
products are doing
why is my model necessary and how it can
drive
impact and also keep learning
and take on different projects
don't say no to opportunities even if
you don't really understand in the short
term
why they're beneficial for me or for the
company
everything i do is part of my job or an
external
volunteering work everything all comes
together and sometimes
two years later i come back to a small
project i did
and i remember some algorithm i used and
um and the dots just click so i would
say just be diverse
take on everything try to learn as much
as you can
learn from people for more experienced
people i think this is one of the things
that allowed me to really advance
quickly
i always found mentors and people to
learn from and it's much quicker to
learn from success
successful people than to make all the
mistakes on your own
and before you you you touched on a
little bit this
the growing trend of of the advancing
technologies that are making the job of
the data scientists a little bit
different there's many more tools
the the expectations are different these
days and so
you know share with me a little bit
about where you think we're heading you
know as a workforce and as
you know is a data science vertical
right and so what what are the different
tools that we're seeing emerging and
where do you think we're going to end up
in terms of the data science experience
and role
so um i feel that a major concern of
people that
talk to me about this domain is the fact
that automl i don't wish automatic
machine learning
um is gaining a lot of traction and
people feel that this in 10 years this
this profession is going to be redundant
um i feel this is like a very major
concern of people that are just now
starting their studies and say okay i'm
just going to enter the workforce within
five years for example
how many years will i even have to
practice data science before
this goes away um i i actually feel that
this is a misconception because
maybe things are going to get easier
meaning training a model and deploying
it is going to get easier there's
many startups a lot of them in israel by
the way that handle the
model monitoring which in the past was
very cumbersome
today there's a lot of software
different sas that
enable you to just buy a small piece of
software
and get automatic model monitoring so
things are easier
but everything is in the perimeter of
the job meaning
business understanding and domain
knowledge is not something that you can
train a
automl algorithm um to just know
feature engineering even in
again maybe some of our audience doesn't
isn't very familiar with deep learning
for example when deep learning emerged
and started entering the industry a lot
of the conversations were around
is feature engineering going to be
redundant because deep learning models
are much stronger than the traditional
tree based models
and people thought that we would just be
able to take raw data throw them on a
deep learning model
and get amazing results and practice
shows that this really isn't the case
meaning
you still need a data scientist that's
proficient in cleaning the data
creating features tuning the model
and also the human connection meaning i
work very closely with the business
and with developers and at the end
everything
is all around people like you can't just
have an
algorithm that sets expectations or
negotiates
um and i feel really feel that these
parts are here to stay
so well-versed data scientists that know
how to handle
um the business as well as the technical
part i feel they're going to still have
their jobs in 10 15 years but hopefully
things will get
faster and easier and i feel that really
the velocity
of the models we're able to deploy has
increased if in the past it would take
me six months to create a new model
today maybe i can do it in
two months maybe in five years i'll be
able to do it in two weeks
so i feel the trend is actually going to
help the data scientists and not really
put us out of our jobs
and so what one of the key takeaways
that i'm that i'm taking away from this
is this idea
that you know while technical skills
are going to be more democratized
because a lot of the things that we now
have
that we need intellectual property in
order to in terms of knowledge in order
to do
they're going to be democratized by
tools like tensorflow et cetera and
automl
but this connection to the business unit
is something
and obviously all of that granted that
you know the really deep stuff the
really
you know hardcore deep learning
complicated models they're probably not
going to be
in auto ml and we're going to need those
functions in the company but
for the average use cases where this
business connection is going to be the
key
and and i think that's it that's a
pretty important takeaway from here as
well and
aviva i really want to thank you for
coming here and i want to spend the last
few minutes going
to talk a little bit more about you and
i'd like to start by going back to your
childhood and asking what
really fascinated you as a kid
um so maybe it's not surprising um as i
ended up as a data scientist
but i loved math ever since i could
remember myself
it was my favorite subject at school i
was like i looked forward to
doing homework in math and i think it
was one of my
greatest realizations is that there the
world is
so vast meaning every year we would
learn a new subject a new subdomain and
the fact that knowledge is endless and i
can just keep on learning
and think about new solutions solving
riddles
i think this really fascinated me and
eventually it led me to the career i
chose
amazing and what is inspiring you today
so today actually i'm interested of
course in technology and algorithms but
i would say that what
really inspires me is the sense of
community i'm part of a few communities
both the data science communities
female technologist communities as i
said before i'm a mentor and mentee
and i think this is one of the things
that really
the networking the the mutual help it
really pushed me i started talking at
conferences
um really i would say this is something
i would never have tried without
the push of these strong communities and
this is what really inspires me in my
day-to-day
i love it by the way regarding your your
love for math
you know i'm trying to imagine you know
in elementary school you're going in
you're you're studying math
what what did you find so beautiful
about it that just got you so involved
with it
i think two things one is that it's the
only subject i
i felt that i was really creating
something in other subject at school you
just learn you're passive you learn
social studies you learn science
you learn history you just like
you have knowledge that's just thrown at
you and you're expected to memorize or
understand
but math for me is something that you
really can create with you can i can
create new problems and solve them i can
think of new things
um so that's really what inspired me the
fact that it's very productive and
it's it's it evolves it's not just
something you have to like
understand memorize and go on to the
next
thing that makes a lot of sense and the
last question that i have for you
is three words you would use to describe
yourself
um so first i'm a data scientist of
course the second thing that may
surprise a lot of people is that i'm a
pastry chef
i studied for one year in parallel my
full-time work as a data scientist um so
i'm a fully trained
uh professional pastry chef um
and mentor i think i spend most of my
non-work hours
mentoring people and this has become
really a strong part of my personality
aviv thank you very very much this was
wonderful and inspiring and
i learned a lot thank you for your time
thank you
take care thank you bye